اتهمت البشر بتدمير كوكب الارض تعلمت لغه
الاشاره وتواصلت معهم لتحذرهم قائله
ساعدوا الارض بسرعه انها الغوريلا كوكو
التي كادت ان تتحدث
تعالوا معنا لنتعرف على قصه جديده من عالم
غريب
عام 71 ولدت الغوريلا كوكو في حديقه
حيوانات سان فرانسيسكو عانت في يومها
الاول من مشاكل الصحيه بسبب رفض امهات
تغذيتها والاعتناء بها ماذا فعل القائمين
على الحديقه لتقديم الرعايه لها بدلا من
امها وبالرغم من كل ذلك كانت كوكو مصدره
جذب لكثير من الناس ومنهم باحثه تدعى بن
باترسون التي تقدمت بطلب لاخذها الى مقر
للابحث في جامعه امريكيه لجعلها ماده
لاطراحه
الهدف الرئيسي للتجربه كانت تعلم المزيد
عن افكار ومشاعر الغوريلا ومعرفه مدى
قدرتها على التفكير وفهم الواقع من حولها
وفي غضون اسبوعين فقط من تدريبها كانت
كوكو اول غوريلا تستخدم لغه الاشاره
الصحيحه للطعام والشراب وبعد سنوات على
علاقه باترسون وكوكو حدثت المفاجاه
الغوريلا تعلمت كيفيه التواصل مع البشر
وافهاما من امامها بلغه الاشاره لقد تعلمت
كوكو وفهمت اكثر من الف كلمه في لغه
الاشاره
كوكو اتقنت لغه الاشاره وبدات في التعبير
عن رغبتها بالحصول على قطه صغيره كهديه
احضروا لها دميه لكنها رفضت اللاعب وعبرت
عن حزنها
بعد حسني كوكو الشديد احضروا لها هذا
الصندوق واختارت منه قطا رماديا كان
رفيقها طيله سنوات تعامله بلطف وتلعب معه
في وقت فراغها حيث كان لديها جدول كامل من
دروس لغه الاشاره والانشطه الاخرى يوميا
كانت تصف القطه بلغه الاشاره وتردد ناعم
جيد قطه لكن الحادث الاليم الذي لحق بهذا
القطه وافقده حياته جعل كوكو تعبر عن
المها مثل البشر تماما فعندما وصلها الخبر
الحزين صمتطت لعشر دقائق كامله وكانها لم
تسمع ولم تصدق ما قاله لها لم تستطع
استيعابه وفجاه بدات باصدار صرخات حزن
عميقه
وعند بلوغها سن الرابعه والاربعين خرجت
كوكو في فيديو على قناتها في يوتيوب لتحث
البشره على حمايه البيئه وعبرت بلغه
الاشاره قائله
انا غوريلا انا ازهار حيوانات انا طبيعه
كوكو تحب البشر كوكو تحب الارض
ولكن الانسان غبي
وبعد نحو عامين من نشر هذا الفيديو رحلت
كوكو عن عالمنا وظلت قدراتها اللغويه محل
تشكيك من بعض العلماء الذين راوا ان هناك
مبالغتا في ترجمه لغتها خصوصا لعدم وجود
توثيق مناسب لما قالته وكيفيه النطبه